I'm Laura Ingram this is Ingram angle
from Washington tonight if you're a
Republican and you're a candidate for
office or you're already an elected
office you have two choices in the world
number one you can join the hard left
or number two you can be attacked by the
hard left that's it those are the only
options
now anyone who thinks that they're going
to be protected because they get invited
on CNN a lot or they're known as
anti-trump you're deluding yourself
the radicals on the left demand total
obedience or sorry allyship
and if not they'll try to drive you from
public life
these tactics go along with the left's
overriding goal of course which is the
destruction of the nuclear family and
America's judeo-christian tradition
take what the left has just done to
never Trump or Senator Ben Sasse
[Applause]
now despite the fact that SAS voted to
convict former president Trump and his
second impeachment trial the left
mobilized to oppose his becoming the new
president of the University of Florida
he's still in contention now he spoke at
a student Forum on campus where about
300 protesters showed up and they called
The Senator homophobic and racist in
between yelling from the audience of
course
remember
this is not about Trump
they think all Republicans are evil
when Ben sass is considered to be too
conservative Ben sass
that tells you a lot about Academia the
inmates are truly running the asylum
then there's Mike Pence even after
obvious efforts his obvious efforts to
distance himself from president Trump
since election night and of course
remember his portraying himself as the
conservative kind of without drama
well none of this has bought him any
good will when he stepped into the belly
of the Beast this week at Georgetown
University
on Wednesday night he spoke at an event
that was hosted by the schools Institute
of politics and public service and also
the young Americas Foundation
[Music]
now despite speaking about the need for
a return to civility in our politics
Pence's appearance Drew disgusting
protests and a boring but predictable
staged walkout
Republican nice guys finished last
just ask Mitt Romney remember what they
did to him
and would be remiss in not mentioning
Glenn yonkin now he won the Virginia
governorship last year by focusing on
the schools it was a really well-run
campaign and he didn't have a lot of you
know trump-like controversy
looking pretty folksy in that fleece
vest yeah sure
but when he rolled up his sleeves to
campaign for GOP gubernatorial
candidates Across America the media made
him a Target
and when he traveled to Arizona to
campaign for Kerry Lake he became Enemy
Number One
now young can Embraces Carrie Lake in
Arizona despite election denialism
Clinton yonkin had moderate Republicans
fooled the rule or the headlines and
there are a lot more
well there's a lesson here
the time for appeasement is over
and it's something that Kerry Lake
turned into a huge plus during her
primary battle and right now she's
offering kind of a master class and how
to put the media back on its heels
let's talk about election deniers here's
150 examples of Democrats denying
election results this is from Joe
Biden's press secretary reminder Brian
Kemp stole the gubernatorial election
from Georgians and Stacy Abrams Hillary
Clinton Trump is an illegitimate
president is she an election denier so
it's okay for Democrats to question
elections but it's not okay for
Republicans it's a crock of BS every one
of you knows it we have our freedom of
speech and we're not going to relinquish
it to a bunch of fake news propagandist
oh that was awesome it was such a
delight to watch and she's going to be
giving the left heartburn for years to
come and we look forward to every minute
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else